les ivy n'est pas un département
protéger pas que je sache manque de
médecins dépassements d'honoraires
l'association ufc que choisir tire la
sonnette d'alarmé un récent rapport
dresse une carte de la fracture
sanitaire en france et le département
n'est pas épargné notamment par les
déserts médicaux
même sur saint quentin en yvelines les
chiffres sont éloquents en ce qui
concerne le nombre de médecins
généralistes sur l'agglomération
le ratio est de 29,3 médecins à manille
alors qu'il est de 70 à trappes et ufc
que choisir s'est aussi intéressé à
trois spécialités dites en accès libre
l'ophtalmologie la pédiatrie et la
gynécologie
il manque des gynécologues sur les
yvelines comme haubourdin beaucoup
d'endroits ils dépassent les honoraires
on n'ouvre plus à la clientèle
dans le département les dépassements
d'honoraires concernent surtout le sud
des yvelines des secteurs comme
chevreuse ou rambouillet à l'accord
national décrit comme historique a été
trouvé le 23 octobre le seuil de
dépassement est limité à 150 %
ufc que choisir souhaite très plafonner
ce dépassement à 40%
une moyenne nationale prise en compte
par les mutuelles et professionnels du
gouvernement sont passés à 150 % avec
diminution possible sur trois ans or on
sait très bien que connaissant l'esprit
français que ça ne se fera pas et ça
risque d'inciter au contraire les
professionnels de santé à rechercher des
secteurs bien dotées déjà de prendre des
dépassements encore plus faramineux
entre les médecins qui désertent
certains quartiers et les dépassements
d'honoraires
l'association de consommateurs préconise
des aides spécifiques pour permettre aux
médecins de s'installer dans des zones
identifiées et de limiter les
implantations dans des zones dites
surdotées